[Music]
Hogwarts is back and we couldn't be more
thrilled to walk through those doors to
see a young Elvis Dumbledore we've
literally been counting down the days
haven't you theories have sprung up
everywhere from the exhilarating trailer
hinting at what the movie might have in
store are you the greatest Potter fan
well watch this video to dive into the
most shocking theories of the new film
broken down by the second
are you as stoked about the Wizarding
World as us then give us a like and
subscribe below for more great videos
like this now on to 10 theories about
the fantastic beasts the crimes of
grunwald trailer credence controls the
imagination that brought us Harry Potter
Hermione Granger and Ron Weasley never
fails to thrill us so what happens
before the Boy Who Lived in the new
spin-off films fantastic beasts Rowling
brings us on a journey with Newt
Scamander
which as you know was expelled from our
precious Hogwarts with the new trailer
there's no telling what could happen but
our first theory takes us off to a
running start credence barebone who had
alluded to died in the first film is
back and it looks like stronger than
ever the trailer gives us a nice taste
of his presences and it sure seems like
he's attempting to control his powers
the adopted beaten half-blood had his
magic suppressed so strongly he became
an obscure eole obscure eole is a young
wizard who develops a dark parasitical
magical force as a result of their magic
being suppressed through abuse either
psychological or physical credence was
losing control of his obscurus which led
him to grave danger in the trailer we
see him sitting on a rooftop with a
curse flying around in another scene he
is actually using a wand which is a lot
for the boy whose adoptive mother shoved
him into an anti Wizarding group in an
attempt to keep him from magic well
credence is back and it appears he's
learning to control his magic the real
question is what will he use his skills
for origins of Nagini this next theory
takes us way back it may be the most
instantly famous theory about the
fantastic beast trailer a new character
maledictis is theorized to turn into
Voldemort's snake Nagini the evil
serpent we met and heard terrifyingly
hiss
in the Harry Potter films this has been
a major fan theory for years and the
trailer could have confirmed everyone's
guesses neguin e's faith with ultimately
linked to Voldemort's as the snake
hoarded a part of his soul Nagini was a
for cracks claudia kim plays the
mysterious character maledictis she is
shown in the trailer with credence
clearly fooling around with obscure old
dark magic we have the information that
maledictis is someone who suffers from a
blood curse which turns them into a
beast another brief moment in the
trailer if you're quick to catch it is
at 1 minute and 17 seconds it's a poster
for the circus of a woman eerily similar
to claudia kim entangled with a snake
underneath the image it reads maledictis
not much is known about how Voldemort's
and Nagini originally came to join
forces but perhaps if this theory is
correct we'll find out in November 2018
Nagini may be an instrument of dark
magic from way back in these early
Wizarding days the Ministry is holding
Dumbledore back Dumbledore has saved the
day on numerous occasions in Harry
Potter however back in his younger days
he surely wasn't trusted as much the
trailer suggests that the films will
begin to explore Alice's complicated
past more deeply as we know from the
books Grindelwald and Dumbledore have a
complicated history both becoming
obsessively interested in the Deathly
Hallows in a tragic turn of events
Dumbledore sister Ariana was killed
while a duel broke out unsure who spell
it was Dumbledore took the blame this
overbearing guilt is what he claims
stopped him from facing Grindelwald to
rise to power in the trailer Dumbledore
sends Newt on a mission instead of
himself going to confront Grindelwald it
also reveals that there could be another
reason Dumbledore wasn't facing his old
friend so is it possible that political
forces held him back from confronting
his frenemy until 1945 when the
fantastic beasts films end 1945 is the
year Grindelwald died in the ominous
duel between the two super wizards did
the Deathly Hollows film sum up the true
history poorly the trailer suggests that
Dumbledore did have to listen to the
Ministry of Magic orders with them all
in his office surrounding him the
tria tempted to sit out Grindelwald rain
so despite Dumbledore's personal
connection with the evil wizard he was
most likely heavily swaddled to not
fight Grindelwald does let a return with
evil motives ah the good old love
triangle may make an unwanted appearance
in our fantasy world involving tina newt
and of course lettle estranged we all
know that newt marries tina goldstein
but his old love and truce is back and
we're pretty sure she's going to be
stirring the pot one way or another and
it may be for a little more than love
this is more of a far-fetched theory but
Letta is back for a reason and if it
doesn't have to do with Newton some way
then we're already lost we theorized
that let is back in some way to
manipulate newts to get what she wants
let it technically use newt ones before
when he took the blame for her mistake
and was expelled from Hogwarts so
there's no saying how far she could go
what do you think well his purposes in
the film will Newton let it get back
together only for new to find themselves
stabbed in the back by 1927 let it
became engaged to newts brother Theseus
and we don't think JK Rowling would have
newts diverted to Letta then back to
Tina for no reason Lana has other
motives and we're sure of it does
Grindelwald escape in the thrilling and
fast-paced trailer we get a better look
at Grindelwald white face the infamous
villain played by Johnny Depp only made
a sneak appearance at the end of the
last film and now he's back for more
Gellert Grindelwald is considered the
second most dangerous wizard after Tom
Riddle an idealistic revolutionary one
at that in the trailer it appears he is
standing before Y Z Jamaat's the
Parliament and High Court of Britain's
Wizarding World though it looks like
Grindelwald will answer for his crimes
we're almost certain that isn't what is
going to go down we mean Grindelwald is
terrifying notorious and a little law
enforcement isn't going to stop it plus
there's proof later in the trailer
a carriage bust through the doors which
is most likely his big escape the
carriage was pulled by festivals a type
of creature that is invisible to anyone
who hasn't seen death we wonder who else
can see the fest rolls Newt and Ministry
officials perhaps the carriage flies
through the air dodging wizards and
witches on brooms next to it clearly
this is some sort of grand break out
inside the carriage we theorize is our
criminal wizard mastermind Grindelwald
or perhaps it was a diversion for him to
escape another way either way
Grindelwald is out and at large
Dumbledore defense against dark arts
professor during the early Wizarding
World we get to see the youth of
Dumbledore played by lovable actor Jude
Law in the trailer though he is not in
the office we know so well to be his we
theorize that he was the professor of
Defense Against the Dark Arts you don't
get that good at fighting off Dementors
and facing he who shall not be named
without all those curses and spells in
the head in the trailer Dumbledore leans
against a desk sweeping windows in the
background the stone walls surrounding a
large room sure looks like he could be
teaching the class the job has been
labeled as cursed in the original books
but what if it was Dumbledore who was
the last uncursed wizard to teach the
class perhaps there is another layer
here we are just discovering did
Dumbledore cursed the position for
future teachers and if so why though
defense against the dark arts is
obviously important maybe he didn't
believe in the students learning such
dark magic after seeing what happened to
Voldemort
perhaps he was trying to protect them
and though he couldn't get rid of the
position he cursed it instead we're
certain Dumbledore has more than a few
secrets of those magic wielding sleeves
maledictis betrayed maledictis it's
going to be a major part of the new film
we speculate maybe even working with
Grindelwald in the end if maledictis
does turn out to be Nagini we suspect
that she works with Grindelwald and when
she tried to leave him he cursed her in
the trailer we see on the poster
maledictis with a snake underneath the
translation of the French slogan reads
in the flesh meaning the audience most
likely gets to see her turn into the
terrifying snake at the circus perhaps
Grindelwald found out about her power
and decided to use it to his advantage
Grindelwald story mirrors that of the
Nazis insinuating that during the Second
World War
wizards and witches may have been
involved printer world is eerily similar
to Hitler and
dies the same year Hitler does Hitler
would use any names necessary to see his
evil goals come to fruition and we're
certain the same goes for Grindelwald as
the burden explodes in the trailer a man
stands in the center unable to make out
who it is we fear eyes it is either
Grindelwald free maledictis or
maledictis using credence to free both
of them and go to the dark lord her
allegiance may have been swayed it
appears the question remains did
Grindelwald curse maledictis to remain a
snake forever freedom's held captive we
already know credence is back but is he
also in the circus or held captive by
the circus maybe this is the reason that
he is learning to control his powers to
possibly escape many theories have
arisen simply stating that credence to
join the circus however were certain
it's darker than that
what if credence is actually being held
captive by the circus this would explain
his visible anger in the trailer as he
attempts to use a wand at another moment
in the circus stunt the audience watches
something or someone in a cage could it
be credence his momentous amount of
magical powers could definitely interest
the circus or kenneth's the traveling
Museum of human oddities credence would
certainly fit that is if they can keep
him captive this fits with why we see
maledictis and credence on the roof with
her seemingly teaching him how to
control his magic maledictis who's part
of the circus as seen on the poster must
have met credence there if maledictis is
on the dark side his powers would
interests her greatly what if she helped
him escape and then began teaching him
magic a picture was released for the
film with maledictis and credence her
arm around him seems to us like that's
one large hint of her taking him under
her evil snake venom control Grindelwald
and Dumbledore together Rowling
announced that Albus and Gellert had an
intimate relationship in the past which
would make sense as to why Dumbledore
took so long to defeat his dear friend
because in fact they were lovers
this theory stems not only from the
mouth of Rowling the newspaper that
dissected this controversy but also in
the trailer Rowling was condemned for
saying that she did include gay
characters in her work when she had in
fact not explicitly
she
to say that Dumbledore and Grindelwald
had been together however this was
nowhere apparent in the books especially
for children so will it be in the new
film it would make perfect sense if they
were lovers making their bond more
complicated as they turn into the good
versus evil wizards we know them as it
seems far-fetched that Dumbledore
wouldn't go defeat Grindelwald sooner
just because of the ministry this theory
makes sense and we love that there is a
potential for gay characters to be seen
in our Wizarding World this relationship
would add another layer of conflict on
the fire the controversy over the
relationship being non explicitly shown
in the film created backlash from fans
which was defended by Rowling we just
hope that they dive into the only
uncharted territory in these films so
far the trailer suggests something is
stirring and there is definitely more
than one level to it what's the
connection between Letta and Creon's
in the trailer there is a small detail
that devoted fans found there is a split
second shot of a man standing in front
of a luminous chart in an unknown area
however if you were to pause and zoom on
that image credence and letter are
linked yep you heard that right with
just this one meticulous pause and zoom
a major part of the plot has been
uncovered credence and Letta
are the children of Corvus Lestrange by
different mothers which makes them half
siblings which then further links
credence into the Harry Potter films
making him a relative of Sirius Black
the evil Bellatrix Lestrange and
Nymphadora Tonks however that's not all
that's shown in the chart it's also a
link to characters racial lineage which
hints at the themes that will be
explored in the second fantastic beast
PopSugar even speculates that with
racism coming into the Wizarding World
it may even mean this film dives into a
deeper exploration of what crimes of
Grindelwald actually means we'll be
lining up outside the theatre in
November but while we excitedly wait do
you have any theories of your own let us
know in the comments below thanks for
watching ten theories about the
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald trailer see you next time
[Music]